はじめまして串田まさやですどうも
よろしくお願いいたします
今までの僕の作品の特徴の一つは様々な
動植物の一部を使用し
組み合わせることによって
装飾としての美しさを靴でそして
彫刻として表現することでし
たまたファッション業界において高級で
あったり
希少価値のある動物の素材を使用すること
も
重要に考えていました
今こちらに
写っている作品は
権利で両足院にある
雪梅融系図という伊藤若冲が書いた
絵からインスピレーションを受けて作った
作品になります左からより今ファッション
的な
靴から少しずつアートに紹介していく3つ
で一つの作品になっています
本体の素材の一部は西陣織を使っていたり
あるいは一番右のくちばしのこと尖って
いるような所っていうのはワニを使用し
たりそれ以外には鳥の羽根などいろんな
ものを多用しています
動物や自然のフォルムはすべての
摂理の中においてその形にならざるを得
なかった最終形態だと考えています
僕はその最終形態をファイナルデザインと
いう風に定義しています
今この瞬間も目に見えないような進化を
続けておりその目に見えない進化は尊く
動植物のフォルムの繊細や美しさに感動し
ます
皆さんはその美しさの理由を考えることは
考えたことはありますか
幼少期に朝日とか
星空を見た時に誰からも教えてもらって
ないにもかかわらず感動した記憶が皆さん
にもあるのではないでしょうか
僕たちは自然の美しさを考えるよりも先に
全身で感じています
そしてその反射的に湧き上がる感動は
理屈ではなくて人類が現在に至るまでに
進化し続ける過程に
蓄積された
遺伝子の記憶だと考えていますまたその
蓄積された遺伝子の記憶は美意識と深く
つながっているのではないでしょうか
昔の人々もそうだったように僕たちは動物
や自然に宿る圧倒的なエネルギーに
インスパイアされ続けています
僕が生まれ育った広島の因島という場所が
一日中自然と触れ合える環境だったという
ことが僕にとって大きく影響しているのか
もしれません
因島の自然は美しさを教えてくれただけで
はなく
畏怖の念も与えてくれました
また自分で船を作るほど手先が器用だった
祖父の影響もありまして僕自身ちっちゃい
時から遊び道具とかは自分で作ったりとか
してました
そうした実体験が今の僕の武器になってる
んじゃないかなっていうふうに思ってい
ます
今でも年に数回その因島には帰るんです
けれども
季節によって変化する空とか海の色だっ
たりとかあとは植物の色彩あと水平線に
重なる島のグラデーションに対峙すると
あまりにも感動しすぎちゃって
涙が出ることもあるんです
同じように
京都の町に住んでいても同じような体験に
遭遇することもありますただそんな中僕は
作品を制作する上で少しずつ変化してきて
いる自分の気持ちに気づきました今まで
当たり前のようにして使用してきた貴重な
素材で作品を作ることへの違和感と行き
過ぎた資本主義におけるファッション産業
のあり方に
疑問を持ち始めたのです
近年世界中でファッションのために搾取さ
れ続けている動植物の素材について見直す
潮流もあります
人の手では生み出せない動植物の素材は
圧倒的に美しくその代わりになるものは
いまだに存在していません
それが故に人々を利用し人々を魅了し
身にまとうことで気持ちを満たし高揚させ
またファッション産業の成長にも大きく
影響してきました
しかし現代では大量生産
価格競争が進み誰しもが低価格で気軽に
ファッションを手にすることができる
過剰な消費社会になってきてると皆様思い
ませんか
その裏側では
搾取され続けてきた動植物への影響だけで
はなく
劣悪な
劣悪な生産環境や
労働条件で大変な思いをしている人も
たくさんいるでしょうもちろん全てがそう
ではないですし
改ざんされているとは思うのですがそんな
ファッション業界に対して一線を書く
僕自身のものづくりは
脱ファッション
言うなれば行き過ぎたファッションへの
反抗の視線で
美意識を持って対峙したいと思うように
なりました
これまでは動植物の
装飾的要素に強く魅力を感じてきていまし
たなのでそれをどう取り入れて美しい作品
を作るかということに注力してきました
ちなみにこの作品は
履けるとか歩くっていうことを重要には
全くしていなくて靴としての概念だったり
とかあるいはそのハクっていうことを想像
した時により人は足を意識するのではない
かなどを
靴の実用性を超越した
靴の彫刻としての表現ということを目指し
て制作しました
かかとのパーツすごくあの綺麗なグリーン
が多く重なってると思うんですけれどこれ
はあのタマムシの羽を大量に使用してい
ます
また
自分の今までのこういう装飾的に魅力を
感じてどんどん作ってきたんですけれども
どうしても自分自身がこの鳥の羽だったり
とかやっぱり昆虫の羽っていうものを使用
するっていうことでその自分の美意識の中
に反する気持ちというものがどんどん
生まれてきたりあるいは人のエゴっていう
ことによってそのいろんな
命を
もらうっていうことをやっぱりどうしても
自分が気持ちよく制作できないなっていう
風に気づき始めてどんどん制作する態度
っていうのが自分自身変わってきました
またここ数年で持続可能という言葉を多く
聞くようになりました
ミラーを見据えて考えると僕はどちらかと
いうと
持続可能っていうよりかは
循環っていう言葉の方がしっくりくるん
じゃないかなというふうに思ってます
ちなみに持続可能の意味は
将来にわたって
持続的
永続的に
活動を
営むこととされていますが
持続的
永続的に活動を続けるためには
循環し続けなければなりません
循環するということは僕は最初にお話しし
たように動植物が目に見えない進化を続け
ていることと同様に美しさがそこにはあり
その美しさに気づくそれぞれの美意識が
大切なんじゃないかなっていうふうに思っ
てます
そして世の中のほとんどのことに
すべての人にとっての正しい正しいという
答えはないんじゃないでしょうか
意外と自分のことも理解できなかったりし
ますよね
だからこそ一つ一つ
意思を持って選択することが大切でその
意志が美意識であり
責任を持つという風につながっていくと
思います
会話や立ち振る舞い作品から
責任のある
選択が見えたとき人は美しいと感じるので
はないでしょうか
こちらは6月に発表した新作なんです
けれどもこの新作のテーマは人には
それぞれの人生がありどんな人でも一生
懸命に生きてかれていくその姿が美しく
尊いという思いから人の人生を花に
靴を牡蠣と見立てて人間参加という風に
タイトルにしました
こちらは正しい記憶という名前の作品なん
ですけれども記憶というものは絶対的な一
つだけの正しいものは存在せず共有した人
それぞれにとって正しい記憶に変化して
いきます
思い出ってその人の都合のいいように美化
されたりもしますよね
そのことを理解することが多様性にも
つながるんじゃないかなというふうに考え
ています
また
移ろいの早いこの社会では正しさを求める
のではなく正しくあろうとする意志の方が
重要ではないでしょうか
例えば小さなことなんですけれども道に
ゴミを道にゴミを捨てる自分は美しいか
どうかを考えられる意識があればそんな
ことはしないですよね
その責任のある
選択の積み重ねが人生を形成し社会を
そして世界を形作ります
結局人を豊かにし行き過ぎた資本主義から
の脱却には個人の美意識が
重要なのではないでしょうか
もしも皆さんが何かしらの選択をしないと
いけない時には誰からどう見られるのかを
恐れるのではなく自分の美意識に従った
意志を持ち自信を持って進んでください
ありがとうございまし
た